je vous jure on n'a pas triché on a
rentré parce qu'on voulait patrie chine
on a rentré les visas dans l'application
on a le classement de la 11e à la
personne numéro facile hein c'est une
application ça ne veut rien dire
c'est selon les traits tout ça moi ça me
fait de la peine pour la personne en
dernière position et c'est pas du tout
méritée n'est pas aussi proche un homme
c'est pas chez moi c'est même si c'est
moi c'est une femme mais remet alors je
vous le dis et je pense qu'ils ont mal
[Rires]
compris ne rit pas
oh
[Musique]
vous l'avez prise ou alors je vous dis
oh parce qu'ils ont mal pris la photo
[Musique]
n'était pas du tout d'accord
non mais sur la tête de ma mère que ce
n'est pas tricher numéro 10
allez on passe vite sur la vente au
numéro dix ogives cgc avec 2003 photo l
est pas mais oui mais c'est très gonflé
tout ça c'est une très bonne note
ah oui je serai content moi arrêtez
arrêtez de dire vous êtes magnifique à
tout le monde
en 9e position dépassant ainsi les
banques
[Applaudissements]
là
jean-michel je vous jure c'est jean
michel vous avez 2,4 était superbe 9e
position huitième position de l'apli
celui qui est le huitième plus beau
ghani et bien c'est oit julien courbet
sérieux avec 2,6 je veux dire ça mais
c'est la belle isabelle elle m'irait
bien
l'application visa et ils sortent la
date c'est le jeu vous êtes 8e je suis
très bien au septième position attendait
en septième position
soit il reste donc valérie il reste
maxime y reste mathieu géraldine bouder
kelly et moi et bien en septième
position
le septième de cette appli soyez ils
sont au stress le septième essai bouder
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue
hélas hélas et la photo est l'aîné ne
vous met pas dans les meilleures
approches mois est sa première fois de
ma vie j'ai la moyenne attention aux
abords sixième position en sixième
position avec 2,8
c'est l'application qui a mis la note en
abyme et julien il me regarda pdc
mission elle a fait une escale sur tf1 a
fait 30 mai c'est une leçon de suspense
comme ça je vais commenter dedans non
mais c'est comme ça à brême en sixième
position
on tient à dos en sixième position pas
mal avec 2,8 ah oui maxime gagnon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors la beauté tout sur cette photo
creuserait position je suis en cinquième
position avec 2
[Applaudissements]
high tech et les garçons y aura six ans
non mais jusqu'à ce que vous vous voyez
beaucoup plus oui 3000 - vous êtes un
bis
excusez moi vous dire j arrive en tête
chez les garçons on a vu un match c'est
un super gars c'est ma cinquième
position et là je vous dis on fait un
bon niveau des notes
ah ouais enfin bon au niveau des notes
qu'en quatrième position c'est géraldine
a très bien avec 3,6
[Applaudissements]
jérémy là on dégote top3 sayah benhaim
kelly et match 11e quel va être le
classement à l'épidémie pour le maroc en
troisième position
celle ou celui qui a été classé plus
beau visage
la porte par l'application oui on a
rendez vous avec l'histoire
après ou pas en diplôme qui vous
demandent de parquet en troisième
position
[Musique]
elle m'a botté par dont trois yachts mas
merveille tpo sérieux veille
maghrabi et
et en tête je vais donner je vous
demander de venir tous les deux comme
israël veut tenir par la main les deux
petits bouts
[Musique]
soyez cool elle a voté en examen qui
sont très beau tollé chez les délits le
final de ouf ça les connaît et vous
ferez des en plus rien des enfants sans
déconner mais un galet sur ma tête ma
mère ils font des enfants ça krisprolls
qui sont élaborés qui a career mon frère
attention même si tu perds sache que
c'était je vais juste honnête je vais
donner le nom du gagnant le ou la plus
belle de tp des prix selon l'application
qui ce qu'ils veulent et la braguette
des médecins qui n'ont pas de toit
allait sa braguette ouverte aux familles
avant les deux parcours bah oui famine
est votre braguette n'est pas ouverte
mais votre gueule un peu trop même et
kelly vous faut je dirais qu'il y aurait
moins si on a un son assise regard des
sondages twitter d'évidence le nom avec
une note de 4 bien que le cac ouvre la
lah énorme sur serait-ce la dncc matinée
au dessus des milliers rage matos
l'automation
il est au dessus de gagner sachez que le
deuxième est une note de 4,2 aussi quand
même un pas mais on sera le grand
gagnant
créé aux essais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]